he is gonna be our door into this topic
this is gonna be our door I want you to
recall when we did sum and difference of
cubes okay I know that was a little
while ago but the whole intention of us
spending a bit of time in the beginning
of the year was to read cement in our
heads right and sort of be the pathway
to this next topic okay so help me out
before we do all the signs what are the
actual algebraic pieces that I'm gonna
fit in there X and then Y x squared Y
squared good okay I've got the same
algebraic pieces for both sum and
difference right and then all I need to
do is vary the signs with circle same
opposite always positive okay
same opposite always positive yep same
opposite always positive fantastic okay
now we're gonna go from here is
something subtly different and kind of
in Reverse right so what we have here is
something that is expanded and we
factorized expansion to factorization
okay it just so happens that the
expansions of this very messy thing
turns out to be a very nice and neat
expansion okay we're gonna now go in the
opposite direction what if we have
something like this okay now this is
factorized we run the other way into an
expansion okay now we are going to get
to the point where we can quit out this
result okay but before we get there well
before we get to that I just have to do
it by hand don't I okay now there are
some steps I can make this easier for me
right this is X plus y times X plus y
times X plus y right well if I take one
of them out one of them will be a square
okay and I'm very good at squares we're
really good at square all right so this
is gonna be X plus y and I'm just gonna
quit my result for a perfect square
which is x squared 2 XY
y squared so far so good and now I'm
going to expand up alright I'm going to
continue so I'll do my X's first
everything by X and then everything by
one this time we actually I join the
distributive law okay I got next cube
there
watch your indices 2x squared Y X Y
squared okay is that all right
of course I could write that as Y
squared X but I'm going to try and keep
things consistent it'll make it easier
for me to number one see the logic
behind it and number two collect the
like terms in a second done the x's do
the wires which i write x red white good
and i finished with oh i cute so far so
good
all right I can see some white terms
help me pick them up I've got an x
squared
I've got 2x squared lies there and I've
got one there yes I'm gonna have three
and in a similar way I've gone next y
squared there and I have two X Y
Squared's then that's it that's all the
like terms there are so what I have is X
cubed plus 3x squared y plus 3xy squared
plus y cubed okay this is good
a couple of things to notice here right
notice just like this was structured
this is supremely structured right can
you see it's highlight it right I've
written it in such a way I've written it
alphabetically so that you can see the
powers of X decreasing there's a next to
the north there we don't need to write
it and in exactly the same way but in
Reverse you see the Y's increasing right
so you have this sort of symmetry there
but that's not the only thing you also
have these coefficients that are also
similar right hmm okay now look at the
coefficients they're kind of suspicious
right if you if you
recognize this you're like 1 3 3 1 it's
kind of sauce we saw this on x squared
right 1 2 1 so we get 4x squared what do
you get for a mom let's climb back up
the ladder
there's x squared X plus y squared
there's X plus y cubed what would be go
this way X plus y so what's the previous
power it be previous won't be 1 right
which is just 1 X plus 1y and I can go
back up one more time all right just X
plus y ^ not which of course is always 1
so what am I seeing
I'm seeing a 1 and then I'm saying 1 1
and then I'm saying 1 2 1 and then I'm
saying 1 3 3 1 and you can bet your
bottom dollar that if I take this guy
what are we going to expect all right so
watch the pattern first these powers
right these high powers they match when
I raise the 2 so I'm gonna start with an
X to the 4 all right I'm gonna leave off
the power then it's coefficients for a
second the next other being execute then
a y the next one will be an x squared
and then a y squared you can see what
the powers are doing right one's going
up one's going down I'll have one X left
here and then a 1 cubed and then and
with a 4 so you see this symmetry and
just like I had this one 1 1 1 2 1 1 3 3
1 the coefficients have been in here out
1 4 6 4 1
okay now we've identified a pattern
mathematics is so much about patterns
now we're just kind of guessing that
this is true we have some reasonable
evidence so far that it's true right but
it's nowhere near proofed we're not
going to get there yet and that's a
little more involved okay
but this destruction right the open
question I want to put on your minds is
why should this which is just made by
addition it's how you make it right
why should this have anything to do with
this okay now we will get to an answer
of that question right but I simply
posed to you now but because we are not
the first people to recognize that this
triangle is important okay even Pascal
wasn't the first person to notice that
it was important it's just the in
Stallone who popularized it so his name
up attached to it okay why why should
this process which even a very very
young child what Edition you could be
like my daughter is six and she can add
numbers that big
okay so six-year-old can make that what
was that - doing this